le soleil brille sur le parking mais
certainement pas dans les coeurs des
salariés de la française de mécanique
leur usine risque de fermer c'est en
tout cas leur crainte avec l'arrêt de la
production de certains moteurs et la
délocalisation d'une autre partie on
nous annonce le départ en gris d'un
moteur l'arrêt d'un autre moteur ça fait
qu'on a eu 800 personnes qui vont rester
sans activité
on nous a annoncé l'arrivée d'une
génération iii du spa simard
mais ce ensemble sans réelle volume
aujourd'hui on est dans l'inquiétude ce
que la direction nous donne pas les
chiffres pour les syndicats la direction
cherche avant tout à faire du profit en
prétextant que la crise sanitaire oblige
à une réorganisation de la production
sans pour autant afficher un message
clair aux salariés la direction psa a
annoncé la fermeture programmée de la
française de mécanique maintenant psa
doit ils l'ont fait en nous retirant les
moteurs nous on retire de moteur sur
trois ce qui fait 1200 emplois en moins
cent mille 500 et le dernier moteur qui
nous ont annoncé dernièrement il fera
que 200 à 300 emplois en sachant que ce
moteur déjà fait sur quatre sites
donc il suffira d'ouvrir une équipe sera
notre site pour fermer définitivement à
la française de mécanique
le secteur automobile semble souffrir de
cette crise sanitaire
le groupe renault réalise un chiffre
d'affaires de 43,5 milliards d'euros en
2020 contre 55,5 milliards en 2019
en tout état cause de grosse inquiétude
ans avec les multiplication des plans de
restructuration en sang sont ici à la
française de mécanique avec la
délocalisation de la fabrication de
moteurs de s'asseoir sur la situation
des fonderies un fonderie de bretagne la
somme fonderie du poitou mdf dangeureux
les inquiétudes sur certains gros sites
industriels du groupe psa et renault
auraient effectivement aujourd'hui on
voit qu'une accélération des plans de
restructuration soit disant accéléré par
la crise non c'est faux gras mais depuis
un certain temps ils ont pour objectif d
localiser les production dans les pays à
bas coûts sachant que dans ces pays les
salariés sont surexploités les
conditions de travail et que ces crabes
et bien sûr c'est à ce modèle là qui
veulent nous emmener mettre en
application sur le territoire national
contacté le groupe c'est l'anti ce n'a
pas répondu à notre sollicitation
selon l'insee en france le secteur oddo
employés environ 217 1000 personnes en
un chiffre en baisse constante depuis 15
ans puisqu'en 2004 c'était près de 330
mille salariés qui travaillent dans la
construction automobile
aujourd'hui ces nouvelles
restructurations ne font qu'assombrir un
peu plus l'avenir du secteur dans
l'hexagone